[Music]
well new efforts to help get more
nevadans vaccinated governor steve
sisalek
is pleading for federal assistance so
las vegas doesn't shut down again
this comes just days after the state
received 2.7 billion dollars
from the american rescue plan victoria
saha has the latest
on the new efforts it's been just over a
month since we returned to 100 percent
capacity on the las vegas strip
it looks like it did before the pandemic
but now
more cases have governor steve sisolak
asking for federal help
his chief of staff michelle white
explains how the money will be used
we're going to be you know tripling down
on efforts to
increase number of vaccination sites
specifically in the valley
targeted at high transmission rates low
vaccination rates
with the help of fema there could be an
additional six to ten vaccination
clinics
we need to have more concerted efforts
to increase confidence
some are taking the wait and see
approach of they wanted to see what
happens
that time is here we can see now what
happens and what we're seeing is that
those who are vaccinated are protected
dr fuhrman leguin with the health
district says
with these increased cases there are
also increased hospitalizations
what we find out is that 95 percent of
the cases
reported in grant county the last three
months are
people who are not vaccinated currently
53 percent of nevadans have gotten at
least
one dose but dr vikas style a
pulmonologist with saint rose siena says
we have a long way to go until copen 19
is no longer a threat
as long as we do up to 70 percent i
think we should
be at a good target and then the rest is
all bonus
dr seil says testing is just as
important as getting vaccinated
those additional vaccine sites will also
serve as testing centers
which will only be made possible with
fema staffing them
victoria saha 8 news now 5
million dollars from federal money is
going towards vaccine nevada days which
serves as a
cash and price incentive for those who
get vaccinated
the governor's office says that that
money will stay in place and the first
winner
will be announced next week